طالبان تعلنها قائلة. نحن ننتظر
فتوى شيوخنا لندخل ايران فاتحين.
وطهران ترد. لن نتهاون في حق
شعبنا ومن يقترب سيندم. يا رسول
واشنطن من بعيد لن نترككم بسهولة
فالعابنا الخبيثة لا تنتهي.
والدب الروسي يترقب ما يحدث
ويقولها للجميع. نحن سادة العالم
الجدد. والخطوط نحن من يرسمها
وليس انتم. ما الذي يحدث في
افغانستان وايران? وهل حقا تخطط
طالبان لاحتلال ايران? وما هي
لعبة واشنطن الخبيثة التي لعبتها
مع صدام حسين وتنوي تكرارها مع
كابل وكيف خدعت امريكا الجميع
وسلحت طالبان من اجل ضمان نجاح
لعبتها الخبيثة. لتعرف اجابة كل
تلك الاسئلة. تابع الفيديو
للنهاية. نهر الدم. هناك عند
الحدود بين افغانستان وايران.
حيث مياه نهر هيلمان. ذروة
التوتر بين البلدين. ياتي شهر
مايو وتزداد حدة التوتر. الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي يحذر
طالبان علنا. لن نسمح حقوق
شعبنا. خذوا كلامي على محمل الجد
حتى لا تعاتبوا لاحقا. القيادي
الافغاني عبدالحميد خرساني يرد.
سنقاتل ايران بحماسة تفوق قتالنا
ضد الولايات المتحدة. ويجب ان
تكون ايران ممتنة لقادة طالبان
على صبرهم. كابل تحشد قواتها
المسلحة عند حدودها مع ايران.
طهران تشعر بالخطر. فطالبان لا
تمزح ولا تنصاع للغة التهديد.
القنبلة اصبحت على وشك الانفجار
طالبان تضرب بالاسلحة الخفيفة
والثقيلة وتندلع اشتباكات بين
قواتها وقوات الحرس الثوري
الايراني خصوصا في ولاية نيمارز
الافغانية. القتلى والجرحى
يتساقطون من الجانبين. المدفعية
الايرانية تستهدف مدينة زارنج
الافغانية. وطالبان ترد بتدمير
اكثر من ثمانية عشر منشأة
ايرانية. عبدالحميد خرساني
يعلنها صراحة. سندخل ايران
فاتحين. على طهران فقط ننتظر ان
يسمح لنا شيوخنا بذلك. يا الهي!
ماذا يحدث? ايران التي ترعب
الغرب اليوم هي تحت التهديد
وطالبان التي كانت تقاتل بالامس
من اجل استرداد حكم افغانستان
الذي انتزعته امريكا قبل اثنين
وعشرين عاما. اليوم تهدد احدى
اقوى دول الشرق الاوسط. وبكل
جرأة حرب المياه لا تعرف الرحمة.
انها حرب الحياة. ولكن مهلا اليس
الصراع على المياه قائما بين مصر
والسودان واثيوبيا منذ اكثر من
عشرة سنوات فيما يعرف باسم ازمة
سد النهضة. ورغم حدة التوتر بين
الدول الثلاث واهمية القضية
بالنسبة لهم. حتى الان لم تطلق
اي من تلك الدول رصاصة واحدة
تجاه خصمها في الازمة. فلماذا
تصل حدة التوتر بين كابل وطهران
الى القتال المسلح وبهذه السرعة?
فما هي كلمة السر في تحويل نهر
هيلمان? الى نهر من الدم. واشنطن
تحرك حبالها الخفي. كل شيء لم
يعد كما هو. فهناك حرب عالمية
ثالثة تطبخ على نار هادئة.
فالتغيرات الجيوسياسية التي
احدثتها موسكو وبكين في الاشهر
القليلة الماضية بالمنطقة
العربية ومنطقة الشرق الاوسط
كالتقارب السعودي الايراني
واعادة سوريا الاسد الى الصف
العربي. وتجريد امريكا من صوتها
الذي كانت تجلد به من يعاديها.
ونقصد هنا عملية ذبح الدولار
ونقصد امتناع روسيا والصين
وحلفائها عن التعامل بعملة
الدولار. كل هذا جعل واشنطن تشعر
بان البساط ينسحب من تحت قدميها
في منطقة الخليج العربي والشرق
الاوسط كله. وهي اهم بقاع الارض
عند امريكا. وكان موسكو وبكين
بعد ان وضعتا ايديهما في الشرق
الاوسط والخليج تقولان لواشنطن.
لم يعد لكم مكان بيننا. ارحلوا
الان. وخذوا عفشكم قبل ان ترحلوا
بدونه. لذا لابد لامريكا من
اختراع ازمة كبرى في المنطقة
لتفتيت اوصالها. وفي هذه الحالة
لن تكون اليد الصهيونية بعيدة
عما يحدث بالطابة. وليس بعيدا ان
يكون في تلك المناطق. ونقصد هنا
المنطقة العربية والشرق الاوسط.
جواسيس زرعتهم واشنطن لامدادها
بمعلومات عن كل ما يحدث خلف
ظهرها. ولكن وبالرغم من اهمية
تلك التغيرات التي حدثت في
المنطقة. وكانت كلها على عكس ما
يشتهي ابناء العم سهام فانها لم
السبب الوحيد الذي جعل واشنطن
تفقد صوابها. بل هناك اسباب اخرى
لا تقل اهمية عن ذلك. فما هي يا
ترى? شبح طالبان وكابوس طهران.
عندما تنظر الى القائمة السوداء
الامريكية او قائمة اعداء
امريكا. فحتما ستجد اسمي كابل
طالبان وطهران في اوائل تلك
القائمة. ولم تنس واشنطن ما
فعلته بهم جماعة طالبان منذ نحو
اثنين وعشرين عاما. عندما دخلت
القوات الامريكية افغانستان
واحتلتها عام الفين وواحد بحجة
حربها على الارهاب. ظنت واشنطن
ان الامر لن يكون اكثر من نزهة
حربية لقواتها. ولكنها فوجئت
بمقاتلي طالبان الذين حولوا
العشرين عاما التي قضتها امريكا
في بلادهم الى جحيم مستمر. ليجبر
الغول الامريكي في النهاية على
الخروج من بلاده صاغرا. ولا احد
يدري كيف وقعت جورج دبليو بوش في
هذا الخطأ الجسيم. وكيف قواته
الى الهبوط في هذا المستنقع.
وحربه ضد الشعب الذي قتل ترسانة
السلاح السوفيتي دون خوف لاكثر
من عشرة سنوات. وانتصر في
النهاية. ولن نبتعد كثيرا عن
الحقيقة اذا قلنا. ان تحدي دبليو
بوش لجماعة طالبان قد كلف واشنطن
الكثير والكثير. وتحولت النسوة
العسكرية الامريكية الى مستنقع
من الوحل. غرقت فيه وانفقت
الكثير. اذا لنذهب الى الاسم
الثاني في قائمة الامريكي ونقصد
ايران وهي الكابوس الذي يتغطى
بعباية روسيا. فطهران دائما ما
تعلنها. لن نعترف باسرائيل ولا
وجود للصهاينة بيننا. فهل هذا
الشعار حقيقة ام انها مجرد اوتار
تعزف عليها طهران لكسب ود العرب
نترك الاجابة هنا لكم. وفي ذلك
الرف الامريكي هناك ملف ايران
النووي والذي بدأ مسيرته في
خمسين القرن الماضي بمباركة
امريكية في ظل حكم الشاه. وانتهى
بان يعد الغول انامله من الندم.
فواشنطن ظنت ان حكم الشاهي
سيستمر للابد. ولكن جاء عام تسعة
وسبعين بصدمة كبرى. عندما قامت
الثورة الايرانية ليبدأ بعد ذلك
نووي طهران مرحلته الثانية
والاخطر. وهي المباركة والحماية
الروسية. واصبح الكابوس المقلق
لواشنطن اليوم. اذا نجحت ايران
في تصنيع السلاح النووي ان اول
اهدافها سيكون توجيه بعضها الى
اهم اعدائها. وانتم تعرفون جيدا
من نقصد. نعم. تل ابيب. حيث
حاولت امريكا مرارا انهاء تلك
الازمة بكل السبل. عقوبات
اقتصادية ضد طهران. العملة
الايرانية تهبط حتى اصبحت لا
تساوي الحبر الذي طبعت به. وفي
الحرب النفسية تطبخ هناك حرب
عسكرية مهددة بالاندلاع في اي
وقت. هنا ايران لم ترضخ لامريكا
في حلمها النووي وكأن شيئا لم
يكن. وهنا كان الحل الوحيد
لامريكا لكي تتخلص من شبح طهران
وكابوس طالبان هي سياسة الضرب في
الخفاء. فماذا فعلت امريكا لتضرب
عصفورين بحجر واحد. اللعبة
الامريكية. عندما انسحبت امريكا
من افغانستان عام الفين وواحد
وعشرين. كانت القوات الامريكية
قد تركت كميات رهيبة من السلاح
المتطور في كابل خلفها. ولم تأخذ
اي شيء. وكانها تقول لطالبان بكل
خبث هو لقد نسينا سلاحا كثيرا
عندكم. انه خطأ غير مقصود منا.
لا بد من ان تستغلوه لصالحكم.
بالطبع استولت طالبان على السلاح
الامريكي. ومن هنا بدأت الخطة
الامريكية الخبيثة. لتشتعل شرارة
الخلافات بين افغانستان وجارتها
ايران دون سابق انذار. وليس هناك
اهم من ان يكون سببا للنزاع هو
المياه. ازدادت حدة التوتر كابل
وطهران ليصل الامر لما حدث فعلا.
طالبان تستغل السلاح الامريكي
المتطور ضد طهران وطهران بالطبع
لن تصمد. ستضرب هي الاخرى
وسيحاول كلا الطرفين الاستيلاء
على نهر هلمان. والذي قد تحوله
واشنطن الى نهر من الدم. حيث
تريد واشنطن اشغال كابل والتي
اعتادت على الحروب بحرب في الطرف
الاخر ضد عدوها اللدود ونقصد
ايران. الهدف منها استنزاف
وارهاق طهران عسكريا وتدمير
اقتصادها هو بالاساس يشكو من
هبوط حاد في الموارد والسبب ذلك.
الملف الذي اثقل كاهلها ونقصد
الملف النووي. وحيث اذا اصرت
وتابعت عنادها لتستمر في قضيتها
النووية قد يكون الحل الاقرب. هو
الحل الذي تتوعد به امريكا
واسرائيل كلما ازداد سعير الخلاف
السياسي. لتدخل واشنطن وتل ابيب
حربهما الموعودة مع طهران وتكون
حينها قد اصبحت لقمة سائغة
ارهقتها الحرب مع طالبان ارهقت
امريكا والاتحاد السوفيتي. حينها
سيتمكن الضبع الامريكي من مضغها
وهضمها بكل سهولة. لتعود بنا
عقارب الزمن وتذكرنا بلعبة
امريكا المفضلة. والتي لعبتها مع
العراق وايران منذ اكثر من
اربعين عاما. حينها كان العراق
يمتلك رابع اقوى جيش في العالم.
واستولى الاسلاميون في ايران على
كمية رهيبة من السلاح الامريكي
المتطور. كانت واشنطن قد دعمت به
نظام الشاهي قبل ان يسقط. فكان
لابد من من القوتين الكبيرتين
والمعاديتين لامريكا. نشب الصراع
بين العراق وايران وكانت واشنطن
تدعم من يضعف منهما. فاذا مالت
الدفة ناحية بغداد كان الدعم
الامريكي ينهار على ايران
وبغزارة. واذا مالت الدفة ناحية
طهران كان الدعم الامريكي يتحول
الى العراق. وهكذا استمرت الحرب
ووجدت بغداد وايران نفسهما في
حرب طاحنة استمرت لثمان سنوات
متصلة واعتبرت هي النزاع العسكري
الاطول العشرين. وكما خططت
وارادت امريكا خرج العراق وايران
من تلك الحرب منهكتين ومثقلتين
بالديون. لتستعيد واشنطن زمام
الامور في المنطقة من جديد.
اليوم جاء الدور على كابول لتقع
ضحية لنفس اللعبة. وطهران لتكرار
اللعبة معها مرة اخرى. ولكن هنا
السؤال. هل ستفلح واشنطن هذه
المرة وتكرر لعبتها لتخرج منها
رابحة من جديد? ان الدب الروسي
واصحاب العيون الضيقة سيكون لهم
رأيا اخر.